forces loyal to Libyan warlord playful
hopped ours say they will enforce a
no-fly zone over the main airport and
the capital Tripoli flights had only
just resumed at motika Airport after
being suspended following a rocket
attack on Wednesday in recognized
government soft are says hopped ours
forces don't have the capacity to
enforce a no-fly zone
however flights in and out of Mattia
have been suspended following the
Warlord's statement we announced the
activation of a no-fly zone that we
previously described as you can see on
this map the no-fly zone includes Mattia
Airport the areas are now forbidden for
civilian or military aviation any
civilian or military aircraft whoever it
belongs to will be in breach of the
ceasefire and therefore will be directly
destroyed the situation in Libya has
been raised at the World Economic Forum
in Davos where Turkey's foreign minister
blamed pop star for standing in the way
of peace the matic editor James BAE's
has more on what he said a meeting of
world leaders last weekend in Berlin was
supposed to bring Libya closer to peace
and cement a ceasefire in the country
and yet there are reports of fresh air
attacks on mitigate airport in Tripoli
carried out by the forces of general
halifa after the Turkish Foreign
Minister has told delegates here in
Davos that one man stands in the way of
peace after didn't make any announcement
as he didn't sign the joint statement
for ceasefire in Moscow this is the only
the problem everybody committed not to
send any additional military force there
by the way our personnel is there for
training and also education nothing is
like a very limited number of we don't
have any strong military presence in
Libya the lack of political progress
means the humanitarian situation is
bound to further deteriorate the UN is
particularly concerned about the
thousands of migrants from elsewhere in
Africa trapped in the conflict zone we
found solutions for a few of them
extracting them evacuating them to other
countries
we have managed to expand a little bit
the space to work inside Libya for those
who can't get out but frankly if there
is no progress on the political front if
military action is not halted that space
will remain very narrow will continue to
be plagued by that tragedy next door to
the European border the next phase for
diplomacy on Libya is slated for next
week in Geneva when representatives of
general hafta are supposed to meet a
team representing phase I'll Suraj the
prime minister of the internationally
recognized government